Speaker 1: Hey, I have to tell you, speaking of
Herschel Walker, some of you may or may not know
Herschel Walker's son, Christian Walker is also a
right winger. He's also a social media influencer.
And he's turned against his father, Herschel
Walker, for being an absent dad and for
endangering him and his mom and so many different
things. Herschel Walker son Christian Walker
actually made a lot of sense talking about Donald
Trump's endorsement record. And this does not mean
that I now agree with Christian Walker's worldview
or anything like it. But on this particular issue,
Christian Walker correctly assesses the
absurdity of the endorsement record that
Donald Trump is touting. Take a listen to this.
Speaker 3: Y'all stop with this endorsement lie.
If I endorsed Ron DeSantis a week before his
election, could I go see his one because of
me? No. He was going to win anyway. He was going
to win Florida. He's done a great job. Just like
if I win, endorsed a Republican and Alabaman
was like, see, my endorsements are amazing,
right? I'm pretty sure a Republican was going
to win in Alabama. Right. Like if a Democrat
endorsed Gavin Newsom, he would he's going to win.
Done. And then you get to you get to brag about
your endorsements in tossup states or whatever.
That's what we're that's what I'm looking for.
Did your endorsements win in tossup states
where we had a chance, then lost or then won?
You get to brag about endorsements if you
have a Republican win in a blue state, but
not Republicans in seats we've had for decades.
Speaker 1: This is spot on. And I have to say,
I'm glad that there is a right winger, including
an extremist right winger like Christa Walker,
who is saying this when Trump and other
pro-Trump Republicans talk about, listen,
209 was the record, or maybe now it's 250
and 15 or whatever. What matters are the
contested elections of consequence. DeSantis was
winning by 12 in the polls, ultimately won by 19.
Trump held off on saying almost anything
about DeSantis until the very end,
didn't even invite him to his rally the Sunday
before the election and counts DeSantis as one
of his wins. What matters is whether you
can deliver victories, either when there is
a contested primary and you influence the primary
and subsequently the person you choose goes on to
win or whether you can influence a toss up state.
He endorsed Mehmet Oz. Trump did. And Oz lost.
He endorsed Doug Mastriano and Mastriano
lost. That was a critical race of significant
importance. He endorsed Tudor Dixon in Michigan
for governor, and Gretchen Whitmer won. He
endorsed Blake Masters, an important Senate seat
in Arizona. Mark Kelly won. He endorsed Kerry.
LAKE It looks like Carrie Lake is going to lose.
He endorsed Jamba Juice. He and John Gibbs, both
of whom I interviewed, check out those interviews
in their respective congressional districts. They
both lost. Those are the endorsements that
are actually relevant, endorsing incumbents,
Republican nominees in safe seats, waiting until
the last minute when you've already seen how
all of the polling shakes out. There is nothing
remarkable about that whatsoever. By the way,
one more. I was curious, how is Christian Walker
reacting to what's going on in Georgia? Because
his own father is now in a runoff election
against Raphael Warnock there. Take a listen.
Speaker 3: I just got home from dinner
and found out that we lost the Senate.
So is everyone saying we had a great
midterm season? We just lost the Senate
before we even get to the Georgia
runoff. So even if we win Georgia,
we've already lost. Because if we win
Georgia, it would go to a. And the vice
president is the tie breaker and sees the.
Speaker 1: Accurate explanation of how the
Senate works. Very good.
Speaker 3: So for everyone
celebrating the midterms, saying we did so good,
congratulations. We lost. Congratulations. Hope
you expect us to celebrate. You think you can
gaslight everyone into saying we had a great
midterms? We lost very easy seats to pick up.
We could have easily won. Good job. Tired of
all this winning? No, I'm sick of losing.
Speaker 1: Okay, so Christian Walker shot
out of a cannon there, and a lot of what he's been
saying lately really does make sense. He will not
be campaigning for his father, Herschel Walker. We
will certainly be working for Raphael Warnock and
I. We're still taking ideas for what we should do.
Should we do a sort of fund raiser, telethon, live
stream, where the more money we raise for Warnock,
the longer the stream goes. Should we do? I don't
know what the privacy rules would be around some
kind of live phone banking. I just don't know.
We're trying to figure it out. But if you have
ideas of how to ensure that Democrats get 51
seats rather than just the 50 and make Joe Manchin
irrelevant. Email info at David Pakman dot com.